Once again we've got a kernel.
We know it's a kernel because it's been tagged with global,
so it's going to run on the GPU but can be called from the host.
Once again we're going to pass in a local variable, a parameter called array.
And the trick is that this parameter is a pointer,
and so this is actually pointing to some global memory that we've allocated elsewhere.
I'll show you how to do that in a moment.
Once you've got a pointer to global memory, you can manipulate the contents of that memory
just as you would manipulate any other chunk of memory.
In this case, I'm going to take my array,
and I'm going to set one of its elements
which happens to be equal to the index of this thread to some number
which happens to be 2.0 times the index to this thread.
Again not a very useful function but it illustrates what's happening.
So the point really is that since all the parameters to a function
are local variables, are private to that thread,
if you want to manipulate global memory you're going to have to pass in a pointer to that memory.
Of course that means you're going to have to allocate a pointer,
so let's look at how that works.
Here's the code to show off how we use global memory.
The first thing I'm going to do is to clear some host memory.
Once again I'm using a convention that's starting a variable with a prefix H_
indicates that this is memory that lives on the host.
Hhere's an array of 128 floats.
I'm also going to declare a pointer that I'm going to use to point
to the global memory that I allocate on the device.
And once again the d_ convention indicates that this variable is on the device.
Now I want to allocate some global memory on the device.
I'm going to use the function cudaMalloc.
What's happening here is that I'm passing it a pointer to this variable which is itself a pointer. Right?
And cudaMalloc is going to allocate some memory in this case room for 128 floats,
and stuff a pointer to that memory into the pointer d array.
If you're allocating memory you'll probably initialize to something.
We use cudaMemcpy for that operation.
In this case we pass in a pointer to the destination memory,
which is this d array that we've allocated,
and a pointer to the source memory, which is this h array variable.
Then the number of bytes allocate, and then we indicate
whether we're copying from the hosted device, or vice versa.
Oops, this is a bug.
Now we've got a chunk of global memory, we've put something in it,
and now we're ready to launch the kernel that's going to operate on that global memory.
So here's the kernel that we saw earlier.
Again, we're going to launch a single thread block, consisting of 128 threads.
I'm going to pass in this pointer where I've allocated and initialized memory.
After this runs, presumably this code will do something to that memory that I pass in,
and now I'll need to copy it back onto the host.
If I want to use the results of this kernel back on the host, then I need to copy the memory back into host memory.
Here's that operation, once again cudaMemcpy.
This time the destination is h array.
The source is d array, this same number of bytes.
Now we're copying from device to host.
That's how you use global memory.
The trick is that, since you can only pass in local variables in a kernel,
you have to allocate and initialize global memory outside the kernel
and then pass in a pointer.
Finally, let's look at how you would use shared memory.